damos inicio a este acto entre las
delegaciones de paz del gobierno de
colombia y las fuerzas armadas
revolucionarias de colombia-ejército del
pueblo farc-ep para presentar el nuevo
acuerdo final para la terminación del
conflicto y la construcción de una paz
estable y duradera y posteriormente se
procederá a firmar dicho acuerdo nos
honra con su presencia el canciller de
la república de cuba bruno rodríguez
padilla
asimismo preside en este acto el doctor
humberto de la calle jefe de la
delegación del gobierno de la república
de colombia y el comandante de las farc
iván márquez jefe de la delegación nos
acompañan igualmente los garantes de
cuba y noruega
iván mora godoy y el señor de milán
se encuentran presentes los
representantes de los países
acompañantes el embajador de la
república bolivariana de venezuela señor
alí rodríguez araque y el embajador de
la república de chile señor ricardo
antonio herrera saldías a continuación
harán uso de la palabra los
representantes de los países garantes
cuba y noruega quienes darán lectura al
comunicado conjunto número 4 tienen la
palabra los garantes
comunicado conjunto número 4
la habana cuba 12 de noviembre de 2016
el gobierno nacional y las farc ep
atendiendo el clamor de los colombianos
y colombianas por concretar su anhelo de
paz y reconciliación hemos alcanzado un
nuevo acuerdo final para la terminación
del conflicto armado que integra cambios
precisiones y aportes de los más
diversos sectores de la sociedad y que
revisamos uno
la construcción de una paz estable y
duradera objetivo al que responde este
nuevo acuerdo debe ser el compromiso
común de todos los colombianos que
contribuyen a superar la polarización y
que recoja todas las expresiones
políticas y sociales
invitamos a todas colombia y a la
comunidad internacional siempre
solidaria en la búsqueda de la
reconciliación a acompañar y respaldar
este nuevo acuerdo y su propia
implementación para dejar en el pasado
la tragedia de la guerra la paz no da
más espera
al finalizar el día los colombianos
podrán consultar en la página www mesa
de conversaciones puntocom punto com un
documento en el que se enseñarán las
modificaciones y los nuevos elementos
la integración total de los textos del
nuevo acuerdo final para la terminación
del conflicto y la construcción de una
paz estable y duradera quedará
disponible en próximos días
agradecemos al garante de cuba- iván
mora godoy y al garante de noruega señor
dar nylander por la lectura del
comunicado se procede a la firma del
nuevo acuerdo de paz entre el gobierno
de la república de colombia y las
fuerzas armadas revolucionarias de
colombia-ejército del pueblo por los
jefes de ambas delegaciones y los
garantes del proceso cuba y noruega
a continuación intervendrá el doctor
humberto de la calle jefe de la
delegación del gobierno de colombia
el señor ministro de relaciones
exteriores
señores embajadores señores
representantes de los países garan
comienzo por reiterar el profundo
agradecimiento de colombia con los
países garantes con los países
acompañantes y en particular por la
generosidad del gobierno de cuba en
habernos tenido acá
en medio de un ambiente de apoyo de
seriedad
de trabajo diplomático impecable durante
más de cuatro años
buenas tardes a todos
después del resultado obtenido el pasado
2 de octubre en el que más de 6 millones
de colombianos expresaron mediante su
voto los reparos al acuerdo firmado
entre el gobierno y las farc
comprendimos que era necesario trabajar
con celeridad y responsabilidad en la
búsqueda de un nuevo acuerdo
y un acuerdo incluyente y respetuoso
a partir del mismo 3 de octubre los
colombianos hemos sido testigos de un
ejercicio profundo de diálogo
además de las múltiples reuniones que
sostuvo el jefe de estado con los
diferentes líderes del no muy
rápidamente designó una comisión
conformada por el ministro de defensa la
canciller y por mí en calidad de jefe
negociador en la que también
participaron el equipo negociador el
ministro del interior el alto consejero
para el posconflicto y el consejero para
el alto consejero doctor sergio
jaramillo
y esas reuniones se llevaron a cabo con
el propósito de sostener diálogos
abiertos y recoger inquietudes
preocupaciones y sugerencias al acuerdo
para la terminación del conflicto
fue un esfuerzo genuino leal que nos
permitió recopilar la totalidad de las
iniciativas ordenarlas estudiarlas a
fondo a fondo
luego de cerca de casi 100 horas de
intercambio directo de opiniones en un
ejercicio constructivo franco y
democrático
después de terminar las reuniones con
los voceros del no viajamos a la habana
para discutir con las farc las
preocupaciones expresadas en bogotá
insistir en la importancia de incorporar
el mayor número de propuestas al texto y
trabajar en la construcción de un nuevo
acuerdo un nuevo acuerdo que cumpliera
en lo posible con las expectativas de
muchos colombianos
las reuniones con la delegación de las
farc fueron igualmente intensas más de
15 días y noches de trabajo muchas veces
más allá de la medianoche reuniones con
discusiones arduas
dada la complejidad de los temas
pero debo destacar el ambiente
constructivo y de buena voluntad de las
delegaciones para trabajar con
disciplina y seriedad
este nuevo acuerdo fue además una
oportunidad para aclarar dudas resolver
inquietudes pero sobre todo para unirnos
los colombianos una vez más nos probamos
que a pesar de las diferencias y
visiones distintas a través del diálogo
es posible llegar a puntos de encuentro
esta tarea la asumimos con compromiso
respeto y responsabilidad pensamos en
los colombianos en sus expectativas sus
inquietudes válidas pero también
trabajamos con la certeza de que no hay
más tiempo que perder no hay más tiempo
que perder estamos convencidos de que
este documento señala caminos viables y
posibles para acabar con tantas décadas
de conflicto en colombia
ahora deseo hacer una confesión personal
dije que el acuerdo del 26 de septiembre
era el mejor acuerdo posible aunque era
también susceptible de críticas y señale
que esa afirmación no se hacía desde la
arrogancia
el mejor por cuanto permitía dar por
terminado el conflicto no para
desestimar las insatisfacciones que
podía generar pero hoy con humildad
reconozco que este acuerdo es mejor en
cuanto resuelve muchas de esas críticas
e insatisfacciones es mejor lo reconozco
pero su aceptación tampoco va a ser
unánime como tampoco lo fue respecto del
primer acuerdo
eso sí esperamos que la base de apoyo
que recoja lo haga más sólido pero más
que exaltar las virtudes de este frente
al anterior acuerdo en lo que gana con
creces es que mediante un ejercicio
democrático se ha logrado construir una
base de sustento más amplia y la
cuestión no es sólo la ampliación del
apoyo sino que éste ha sido fabricado en
un ejercicio leal de democracia y
diálogo sin ser
a los otros 6 millones de votos que nos
acompañaron en la refrendación del
acuerdo quiero decirles que los ajustes
y precisiones que hemos realizado no
sacrifican las convicciones que le
dieron forma al primero
no cancelamos la ilusión no dimos marcha
atrás en la posibilidad de un país nuevo
no desistimos del propósito de
reivindicar la familia campesina limpiar
la política combatir las bandas
criminales y la corrupción contribuir a
superar el problema mundial de la droga
e impartir justicia pensando más en las
víctimas que en los barrotes integrar
nuestros territorios superar
desigualdades ancestrales crear una
sociedad más equitativa y crearla a
través del diálogo del uso razonable de
la autoridad del estado buscarlo
buscando darle cimientos fuertes a la
seguridad humana escuchando sobre todo
escuchando a los más débiles
ahora quiero destacar algunas de las
innovaciones de la cuerpo
durante el término de la dejación de
armas las farc presentaran un inventario
de bienes y activos para destinarlos a
la reparación material de las víctimas
en cuanto a la jurisdicción especial
para la paz se atendió la mayoría de las
propuestas formuladas se precisaron de
manera concreta las características y
mecanismos de la restricción efectiva de
la libertad para todos los responsables
todos
en efecto se fijaron los espacios
territoriales específicos para el
cumplimiento de las sanciones con un
tamaño máximo a las igual a las zonas
veredales se precisaron los períodos de
ejecución de las acciones reparadoras la
precisión del lugar de residencia los
mecanismos de monitoreo y de regulación
del sistema de autorización para los
desplazamientos por fuera de las zonas
requisitos necesario en todos los casos
por iniciativa de algunos opositores se
aceptó que mientras entra en
funcionamiento la jurisdicción especial
las acciones reparadoras debidamente
verificadas pueden ser descontadas de la
sanción que se imponga
sobre el discutido tema de la conexidad
del narcotráfico con el delito político
el acuerdo es que los magistrados
tendrán en cuenta caso a caso la
jurisprudencia de las cortes colombianas
de las cortes colombianas se eliminan
los magistrados extranjeros pero se
acepta la presencia de los llamados
amicus curie expertos extranjeros que
tendrán la función de rendir conceptos
sobre los casos que se transmiten
queda claro que entre la normatividad
aplicable se incluye el código penal
colombiano y que las normas
procedimentales deberán ser incorporadas
al ordenamiento legal serán de
competencia de la jurisdicción especial
las conductas de financiación o
colaboración con actores del conflicto
en que hayan incurrido los terceros no
combatientes que tuvieron una
participación activa o determinante en
los crímenes más graves
esto es eliminó la participación
habitual y se reafirmó que los demás sí
contribuyen a las medidas de verdad y
reparación pueden beneficiarse de la
renuncia de la acción penal u otro tipo
de terminación anticipada del proceso
se estableció también el término
concreto de duración de la jurisdicción
se eliminó la idea de incorporar el
acuerdo a la constitución política y al
llamado bloque de constitucionalidad el
principio general de garantía de
cumplimiento es el compromiso de que
ambas partes cumplirán de buena fe lo
pactado y en lo que tiene que ver con el
estado los principios que informan el
acuerdo serán parámetros de
interpretación
de la aplicación normativa y práctica se
estableció también que la revisión de la
tutela contra decisiones de la
jurisdicción especial quedará en cabeza
de la corte constitucional
en el nuevo acuerdo se define que se
entiende por enfoque de género significa
el reconocimiento de la igualdad de
derechos entre hombres y mujeres y de
las circunstancias especiales de cada
uno supone reconocer que el conflicto ha
impactado de manera diferenciada a la
mujer y que en consecuencia se requieren
acciones distintas y específicas para
restablecer sus derechos incluye también
un principio de respeto a la igualdad y
no discriminación que implica que toda
persona independientemente de su sexo
edad creencias religiosas opiniones
identidad étnica así sea como
perteneciente a la población lgtb o
cualquier otra razón tiene derecho a
disfrutar de todos sus derechos no es
una redundancia tiene derecho a
disfrutar de todos sus derechos
ningún contenido del acuerdo final se
entenderá o interpretará como la
negación restricción o menoscabo de los
derechos de las personas
en atención al llamado que nos hicieron
de diversos sectores religiosos se
estipula que en la implementación de lo
acordado se deberá respetar la libertad
de cultos lo que significa el
reconocimiento y respeto a la práctica
de cualquier manifestación de
religiosidad
mantenemos vivo el compromiso con el
campo a través de una política de
recuperación de la familia campesina que
impulse el acceso equitativo a la tierra
y que cree condiciones de vida digna en
la reforma rural integral hemos afirmado
que nada de lo establecido en el acuerdo
debe afectar el derecho constitucional a
la propiedad privada también quedó
explícito que los programas cuyo
destinatario es el campesino no impiden
la puesta en práctica de diversas formas
de producción tales como la
agroindustria o el turismo
para lograr darle la mayor solidez a la
reforma rural se ajustaron los tiempos
de implementación a las nuevas
realidades fiscales el acuerdo además
por sí mismo no crea zonas de reserva
campesina
desde el acuerdo de cartagena se había
dado un paso inmenso en la lucha contra
el problema mundial de la droga las farc
se comprometieron a romper todo vínculo
con él ya cooperar en la superación de
ese fenómeno ahora en el nuevo acuerdo
se ha logrado precisar de manera
concreta las características de esa
cooperación y además quienes acudan a la
jurisdicción todos todos no sólo las
farc quienes acudan a la jurisdicción
deberán informar de manera exhaustiva y
detallada sobre las informaciones de las
que dispongan para atribuir
responsabilidades
de igual modo se aclara que los
programas de sustitución buscan tener
territorios libres de cultivos de uso
ilícito de modo que no se establezca un
marco de coexistencia entre el programa
de sustitución y la continuación de
tales cultivos
en cuanto a la aplicación de las
políticas sobre el consumo se robe usted
es el papel de la familia y de los
grupos religiosos
se estableció el compromiso de respetar
respetar el principio de sostenibilidad
de las finanzas públicas en tal sentido
el plan marco acordado para las
inversiones deberá contener las fuentes
de financiación
a partir de hoy como se acaba de decir
los colombianos podrán consultar los
cambios y los nuevos elementos del nuevo
acuerdo en las páginas de internet de la
presidencia de la republica de la
oficina del alto comisionado para la paz
del equipo paz gobierno y de la mesa de
conversaciones ya dijimos que en el
transcurso de la próxima semana estará
disponible la versión integrada una vez
se haga el ensamblaje de las
innovaciones y el acuerdo original por
orden del señor presidente de la
república quedamos a disposición de los
voceros de los diversos grupos del nou
para explicar los términos del nuevo
acuerdo suscrito hoy
estimados señores y señoras
no podemos pedir que cese la discusión
pero si podemos desear que la gran
decisión nacional sea poner en marcha la
ejecución de los acuerdos
superar el conflicto armado abrir
caminos a la reconciliación y
profundizar los esfuerzos para lograr
una sociedad más equitativa
ese es el reto ahora es un reto hoy
termina algo y empieza también una nueva
etapa es el reto de nosotros
por nuestros hijos y por nuestros nietos
muchas gracias
el doctor humberto de la calle por su
intervención y ofrecemos la palabra al
comandante iván márquez jefe de la
delegación de las farc ep
y nuestro saludo cordial al ministro de
relaciones exteriores de cuba bruno
rodríguez y por su intermedio a los
comandantes fidel y raúl que
generosamente ofrecieron su territorio y
la logística necesaria para que los
colombianos resolviéramos nuestras
diferencias
saludo a los representantes de los
países garantes noruega y cuba
que estuvieron siempre al lado de los
plenipotenciarios en los momentos más
difíciles y los de satisfacción
impulsando contra viento y marea los
avances de la mesa
un saludo
a los ángeles de la guarda del proceso
de paz como los denominó roy chaderton a
los acompañantes de la república
bolivariana de venezuela y a la
república de chile
a nombre de colombia
a nombre de colombia gracias por
ayudarnos durante tanto tiempo a
encontrar la senda de la reconciliación
y la paz
gracias por su inmensa solidaridad
doctor humberto de la calle y
representantes del gobierno de colombia
compañeros de la delegación de paz de
las farc
y un saludo muy especial al futuro de
colombia aquí presente a su juventud
compatriotas
hemos trabajado de manera incansable día
y noche para entretejer en un solo
cuerpo de consenso los elementos del
nuevo acuerdo final sobre el que
empezaremos la edificación de la paz
estable y duradera para colombia
en el día de hoy como resultado de la
inquebrantable voluntad y decisión de
las partes
de su perseverante búsqueda de una
solución política a la dilatada
confrontación armada
presentamos a la nación colombiana el
nuevo acuerdo de paz definitivo que
preferimos llamar el acuerdo de la
esperanza poderoso instrumento para la
democratización del país y para la
materialización de los derechos de la
gente
han sido semanas de arduo trabajo de
audiencias sucesivas
de ejercicio humilde de escuchar con
interés y respeto de interlocución con
el más amplio espectro del movimiento
social y político y de las iglesias
han sido semanas de muy difíciles pero
fructíferas conversaciones con la
delegación gubernamental que han
permitido reafirmar la vocación de paz y
reconciliación de un país
al tiempo que han posibilitado
comprender y aclarar dudas e inquietudes
razonables de diversos sectores de la
sociedad y también desvirtuar
tergiversaciones
y falacias respecto al acuerdo suscrito
el pasado 26 de septiembre en la ciudad
heroica cartagena de indias
el resultado del plebiscito del 2 de
octubre produjo un impacto que además de
atascar los mecanismos de implementación
previstos pusieron en serio riesgo cinco
años de esfuerzos en la búsqueda de la
reconciliación
pero para fortuna de millones de
compatriotas
la paz
sigue su marcha irrefrenable
irrefrenable
las espontáneas y multitudinarias
movilizaciones sociales de apoyo a la
paz activadas por la juventud
las numerosas manifestaciones de
organizaciones sociales y populares
de partidos y movimientos políticos y el
reiterado acompañamiento de la comunidad
internacional nos incitan a pensar que
se ha iniciado
un cambio histórico hacia una sociedad
auténticamente democrática pacífica y
justa
los resultados de octubre también nos
llevaron a pensar en el sentido más
reflexivo acerca de los límites de la
democracia liberal y de la regla
mayoritaria particularmente cuando ésta
se establece bajo las condiciones de
mayúscula abstención y cuando están de
por medio decisiones de semejante
trascendencia como las que conciernen a
la posibilidad histórica del buen vivir
y en paz para las nuevas generaciones
recordamos en este contexto nuestras
visiones de democracia discutidas en la
mesa que apenas alcanzaron a ser
recogidas de manera muy parcial en el
acuerdo sobre apertura democrática
y reforzamos nuestras certezas acerca de
la necesidad de luchar por nuevos
entendimientos diseños y procedimientos
democráticos que trasciendan el sin el
simple sufragio a fin de garantizar una
verdadera participación social y
ciudadana en los asuntos que inciden
sobre la vida nacional
aún en condiciones de esa precariedad
democrática en la medida en que
accedemos al procedimiento de
refrendación plebiscitaria en la
búsqueda de la paz deseada entendimos
que pese a la débil mayoría
teníamos el compromiso político de
aceptar el resultado adverso y de
atender las múltiples voces que no
habían propiciado distinguiendo entre
aquellas que manifestaban preocupaciones
sinceras por un nuevo y mejor acuerdo y
otras que tenían la pretensión de
dirigirse en obstáculo para el logro del
propósito superior aunque dada la
coyuntura se cobijarán también con el
manto y el discurso de la paz
comprendimos mejor entonces el sentido
del pluralismo y de la diversidad
de los intereses particulares y de
grupos y sectores específicos del
conglomerado social en medio de la
conflictividad que es inherente al orden
vigente
merecen respeto y reconocimiento el
mismo que demandamos hacia nosotros
así es
es que en atención a ello nos dimos a la
tarea junto con el gobierno nacional de
reabrir la discusión en la mesa de la
habana para considerar con el rigor
exigido por las circunstancias todas y
cada una de las propuestas de precisión
y ajuste del acuerdo suscrito el 26 de
septiembre bajo el entendido que se
trataba de un perfeccionamiento de lo ya
convenido teniendo en cuenta lo
manifestado por todos los sectores
políticos y sociales que participaron en
un plebiscito cuyos resultados no debían
comprenderse como una negativa al
acuerdo de paz sino como un llamado a su
mejoramiento
aunque la décima conferencia nacional
guerrillera refrendó el texto de un
acuerdo que para nosotros ya estaba
cerrado comprendimos la importancia de
reformular lo con un mayor consenso que
incorporar a muchas voces que estuvieron
ausentes durante el proceso de
conversaciones y que incluso habiendo
dicho no tienen su sentimiento del lado
de la reconciliación
somos conscientes de que la posibilidad
real de desatar la potencia creadora de
los acuerdos descansa sobre su
legitimidad política y social
por tal razón nos producen una inmensa
satisfacción a anunciar que al tiempo
que el nuevo acuerdo alcanzado preserva
la estructura y el espíritu del primer
acuerdo convenido incorpora un sinnúmero
de ajustes y precisiones que formula
aclaraciones y despeja dudas donde se
consideró necesario por ejemplo en
materia de jurisdicción especial para la
paz se incorporaron no menos del 65% de
las propuestas provenientes de los
diversos sectores que votaron no en el
plebiscito
casi el 90% de las iniciativas referidas
al polémica al polémico tema de género
y algo más de 100 variaciones que tocan
los temas concernientes a la reforma
rural integral
participación política nueva política
antidrogas víctimas fin del conflicto e
implementación y verificación
al respecto de nuestra parte hemos
cedido incluso extendiendo las fronteras
que nos habíamos trazado desplazando las
hasta los límites de lo razonable y
aceptable para una organización
político-militar cuyas almas no fueron
vencidas que acudió por tanto a la mesa
de una a una negociación y no a un
proceso de sometimiento y que ha tomado
la decisión de participar en la vida
política legal si se cumple un conjunto
de condiciones que lo haga posible
le decimos a la sociedad colombiana que
hemos realizado nuestro mejor esfuerzo
por responder a los anhelos de paz
y podemos afirmar con la frente en alto
que hemos cumplido y que al nuevo
acuerdo el único camino que le espera es
su implementación teniendo en cuenta que
con él quedan sentadas las bases para
comenzar una tarea aún más difícil y
compleja la construcción de una paz
estable y duradera a la que esperamos se
puedan sumar con nuevos aportes fruto de
su negociación
los compañeros del ejército de
liberación nacional y que toda la
institucionalidad del estado el poder
ejecutivo el congreso de la república
las altas cortes la fiscalía general de
la nación las fuerzas militares y de
policía asuman su respaldo
con el nuevo acuerdo final se generan
condiciones para iniciar el difícil
proceso de la reconciliación nacional'
propósito que compromete a las
diferentes clases sociales al
empresariado nacional a los sectores
medios de la población a la clase
trabajadora urbana y rural a los
intelectuales y artistas a los
trabajadores de la cultura a las
comunidades campesinas indígenas y
afrodescendientes a la comunidad lgbt
a las mujeres y hombres del común y
desde luego a nuestros guerrilleros que
con expectativa han estado en paciente y
disciplinada espera y también a todos
los partidos y movimientos políticos y
sociales
la firma de este nuevo acuerdo debe dar
inicio a la construcción del país de la
concordia que llevamos en el corazón y
con el que hemos soñado durante toda la
vida pero solo acuerdo no es suficiente
porque un papel florecido de promesas y
buenas intenciones sin veeduría
ciudadana fácilmente puede ser
arrastrado por el viento de la desidia
hacia el desierto de la nada y la
frustración de la esperanza
lo reiteramos el principal garante del
cumplimiento y la implementación de los
acuerdos además del componente
internacional es el propio pueblo y sus
organizaciones porque nadie mejor que él
puede sentir la urgencia de su
concreción porque toca con su dignidad y
su derecho a vivir en paz
está triunfando la paz no lo dudamos nos
sentimos orgullosos de que colombia siga
siendo referente mundial de paz
reiteramos el llamado que hiciéramos con
el gobierno a concertar con todas las
fuerzas vivas del país un gran acuerdo
político nacional encaminado a definir
las reformas y ajustes institucionales
necesarios para atender los retos que la
paz demande poniendo en marcha un nuevo
marco de convivencia política y social
es tiempo de paz de despliegue de una
contienda política que admita si en el
ejercicio estructural de la violencia y
el recurso de las armas la existencia de
diversas visiones de sociedad y en el
que se pueda luchar por ellas por la vía
democrática
que la contienda se traslade al campo de
las ideas
enarbolando en lo más alto de las
conciencias la bandera de la verdad y de
la honradez
que nadie trump que los sueños y las
esperanzas de millones de almas hagamos
de la paz una condición estable y
duradera sobre la base del respeto a los
derechos del pueblo y la justicia social
nuestro futuro está fuertemente ligado
al derecho a la tierra a la salud a la
educación a la vida digna para que nadie
en colombia recaiga en la desesperanza
ha llegado el momento de la construcción
de sueños y de darle vida a la esperanza
mediante la lucha política llenando
nuestros corazones del más inmenso amor
por la patria con la voz del tribuno del
pueblo jorge eliécer gaitán digamos una
vez más bienaventurados los que
entienden que las palabras de concordia
y de paz no deben servir para ocultar
sentimientos de rencor y exterminio
que renazcan entonces de la luz de este
acuerdo de paz
las mariposas amarillas de mauricio
babilonia para que invadan con su amor y
reconciliación todos los rincones de
este gran macondo que es colombia amamos
la paz amamos a colombia que dios y el
comandante manuel marulanda vélez
bendigan este acuerdo muchas gracias
agradecemos al comandante iván márquez
por su intervención y damos por
concluido este encuentro agradecemos a
todos los participantes su presencia
muchas gracias y buenas noches